I want everybody to understand I'm going
to look into this camera right here so I
hope you see me very well here I want
everybody to understand and remember
that everything I say from this point
she backed it up all right so it's
basically zero all right you have no
hope no chance past the 20 years and
that comes from experience it also is
the experience you have no chance of
passing 20 years you're saying no no you
can pass 20 years and probably be
roommates and you'll probably be
overweight in a bust that Pillsbury
biscuit can or you'll probably be with
the exception to the rule but the data
shows us plus the experience that she
expressed that it's a very difficult
thing and this is what I want men to
know yeah it is very difficult many
people will simplify it for you they
will say oh just do this and do that and
they will lead you on a wild goose chase
and that's my perspective that's all
that I offer I tell men to not get
married especially when you don't have
leverage however I also tell you do not
listen to people who simplify this this
is a very complicated thing that most
people fail at miserably
because you used a few things there yeah
about not getting married you said
sometimes you're trying to leverage okay
if you don't have leverage we'll talk
about that yeah and you talk about
turning into roommates well this guy is
the roommate the host of The Roommate
channel right
um when you're hearing this you've been
married one year and by the way this
guy's a sharp informed very intentional
guy he's my assumption is he didn't just
trip and fall into marriage he's seen
myself before okay gotcha so you've been
you've been very you're a calculated
dude okay so when you're hearing Greg
say this yeah and even when you're
hearing Ali say this how are you
processing this information this is
really good and I'm excited about how
this conversation can develop because I
think you've maybe did you react to me
in ams's conversation a couple years ago
about marriage I didn't react to it I
didn't do reaction videos but yeah I
made a comment about okay you made a
comment about it okay so um so to me I'm
really excited about it but it's also
key to talk about experience experience
shapes review right yeah so a girl who's
been abused by a lot of different men
she's gonna have a very cynical leading
view towards men a man who's been
cheated by business partners will have a
very cynical view about having potential
business partners so it's also unique to
talk about where does my where to be
honest nobody here is 100 objective
that's one of my arguments always with
red pill stuff they said they're
speaking of Truth and you're not a robot
you know you're you have your biases
right call it for what it is we all have
our biases I have biases you have biases
coach has biases as much as we think we
are we have to be 100 honest to the
people about our biases if I'm an
individual and I was divorced and I had
a difficult experience via marriage I'm
gonna have a bias opinion via marriage
um Ali has a positive experience with
marriage so she can have a bias towards
well great marriages can work right so
seems similar to me the people I admired
the most the people I look up to are
married People Patrick David Jordan
Peterson my father Pastor Mark Driscoll
people who I look up to the most right
long-term marriages the people that I
celebrate don't a lot long-term marriage
is my father and mother been married for
over 30 years great healthy marriage so
that's my opinion my pastor Pastor Heidi
Lewis been married over 25 years so I
that's my world view
and so to me hearing what he's saying
sharing there is truth in that
everything where everyone's going to
share it's gonna be truth in it yes if
you like my dad told me a very powerful
boy I love my father he's so such a wise
older man he said the most important
decision you'll ever make in your life
is the one you marry and it can and it
can go one of two ways and this is the
this is what I want the guys to
understand we're not teaching naivete
which is oh marriage is perfect thing
and you just meet the one and live
happily ever after and there's no issues
there's no divorces that's we're not
teaching naivete marriage can be the
worst thing in your life it can be an
absolute living hell and I guarantee you
you can go for days and for days and you
know so many different stories about
people with marriage is an absolute
living hell but we don't want to teach
being being naive about the realities
but also we don't want to teach nihilism
right the other end of the extreme
marriage is the worst thing possible and
the women are out to get your money and
everyone's miserable and everybody's
roommates and everybody is this because
there are some individuals such as with
Alex communicated who are in happy
healthy long-term marriage right so you
don't want to be naive you want to be
nihilistic you want to be as real as
possible give me the good the bad and
ugly and my biggest thing is that I
understand that marriage is a very
difficult thing to get right and and the
same thing is like I love how what you
do is marriage and money right I think
we're gonna be talking about those two
things today Adam you're a one percent
man financially
right that means 99 of people are trying
to get to where atom is most people live
paycheck to paycheck they're struggling
their lives suck when it comes to money
most people are struggling but they're
trying to get where to where you are
that's how I view relationships most
people are in really sucky relationship
most people it's a day-to-day War hell
the way work is the way the gym is but
then there are some people who are
having it at the highest of level the
same way we don't nobody says oh well
most people are not going to be in the
one percent so it's true it you should
even try it's oh my oh yeah you know 90
of businesses ending in in 10 years you
should even try we say if somebody's
gonna succeed why not use which I love
what you're doing if someone's going to
be rich why not you if someone's gonna
make money why not you someone could
have a great podcast why not you so for
me I acknowledge that that the top of
the mountain is rare I acknowledge that
but what I also acknowledge is that if
somebody's gonna win why why not it be
you and how can we help as many men as
possible get there everybody won't be
able to get there but how many people
how many people can we help get there
and that's what to me matters the most
strange I love that now when you hear
something like this obviously he's sort
of saying all right I hear you coach
your marriage didn't work you got out
you know thank God before the 10-year
Mark so you'd probably be a little bit
more spiteful than you are not saying
that you're spiteful but you'll be even
more spiteful if you're paying a
ridiculous amount of alimony and
everything you've been paying but is
there anything wrong with it if he's
saying he's basically saying I hear you
coach It Ain't Easy out there brother
like life's tough marriage is tough
getting making money is tough things are
tough but don't tell me that I shouldn't
get married or don't tell me that I
can't have a successful marriage how do
you process that I don't think anyone
says do not get married I think they
caution people to say do not get married
if I say do not get married without
leverage that is a position right that
you can change thus if you read my book
it says once you get to that position
you can then make the decision you'll
probably come out better yeah then going
in it without it however this is what I
will always say when men do find that
that solution does not work out they are
left alone
there's nobody to help them so people
encourage people hey why not give it a
try but when you go bankrupt when you
lose your kids when your kids are taken
from you when the courts kind of punish
you for making this decision or punish
you it punishes you for being a slightly
better higher earner then nobody's there
with information nobody's there with
context no one's there to help them and
I believe not feel I know understand
believe and I have evidence to show that
men are left alone when they don't
succeed in this endeavor and that is the
void that I feel because I can tell you
hey men are alone in this situation men
are homeless men are thinking about
eating guns men are thinking about they
have no way out men are losing big time
and we're losing a fraction of men
through due to manipulation due to
people trying to you know they may be
heard a woman might be hurting a
marriage or she might feel that she's
not being appreciated and then she
throws a grenade in the room what
happens then see that's where where I
come in I get to show you what happens
when the grenade is there and I also
encourage you you're not alone in this a
lot of people come to my content and
they find out oh you too see before as I
said 70 years ago 40 years ago 30 years
ago there was nobody presenting this
side of the Box this side I see what
you're saying this right here nobody
they just left me in alone and said well
you must not have been hitting it right
or you must not have loved it right or
you must have abused the kids that's
what she said she said that you were and
nobody came to this position so I
listened there was a void open and I ran
right yeah so so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
[Music]